I'm familiar that academics who love to
spend really interesting scenarios
involving unsolvable moral dilemmas you
know that's something that that's really
fun if you're running a seminar at
Harvard University I think it has
virtually no relationship to what goes
on in the real world so you know that
so-called ticking time bomb scenarios
what you refer to and people say well
what if we get a terrorist and we know
that that terrorist knows where a bomb
is gonna go off in 48 hours that's gonna
kill a lot of innocent people and he's
not willing to tell us we're wouldn't
you be willing to torture that person
under that circumstance if that's the
only way to get the information a lot of
ifs there in that in that scenario
problem is in the real world it doesn't
happen first of all you never pick up
somebody and you know that that person
knows a bomb is going to go off you
never know that there's a bomb about to
go off at a particular time but you
don't know where it's gonna go off and
then suddenly by chance you capture
someone and you know that that person
knows the one thing that you don't know
second of all in the real world you pick
up a terrorist who's a member of a cell
or an organization that is in fact about
to do something really awful the very
fact that you have arrested that
terrorist means almost certainly that
his cell door organization is going to
cancel their plans or alter them because
they know that they're going to be
compromised and so in the real world
when we pick up people when the CIA
picks up people or the military or the
FBI what they're asking about is not the
ticking bomb what they're asking about
is who are the names of your
co-conspirators where do they bank what
are their cell phone numbers tell us
about how you operate the kinds of
things that you are planning not because
we know those things are going to happen
but just to get us
of how they operate and all of those are
really vital pieces of information and
you interrogate a hundred people in
al-qaeda you put all that stuff together
you're going to avert attacks and you're
going to save lives but it's not the
same thing as a ticking bomb and
everybody we pick up in Afghanistan
everyone we pick up in Iraq everyone we
pick up in a safe house in Paris or
London or Manila may have some small
piece of that larger puzzle and so in
the real world when you start making
this ticking bomb argument and you apply
it to those cases eventually you end up
torturing hundreds or thousands of
people which is what happened so it's a
fun academic exercise that has very
dangerous consequences in the real world
torture is incredibly useful if your
goal is to extract confessions from
people now if I know that I want you to
tell me that you were plotting to
overthrow the government of the United
States or Saudi Arabia or of Russia or
of China torture is an incredibly useful
tool to get you to tell me that even if
it's not true and that's what it's used
for by brutal regimes around the world
if my goal is to humiliate you to punish
you to make you feel helpless to make
you feel like there is no hope for you
and I am in total control over you
torture is an incredibly effective tool
and that's another thing the torture is
used for by brutal regimes around the
world but if my goal is to get you to
tell me something that is true and that
I don't already know
torture is one of the least effective
methods that I can use because what
you're likely to do if I torture you for
some information is to try to calculate
in your own mind what do I want to hear
and then you're going to tell me that
thing that I want to hear so that I
stopped torturing you but what I want to
hear may not be the truth it may just be
what I want to hear so most experienced
intelligence gatherers and interrogators
will say it's the worst thing you can do
and I think looking back over the last
eight years we probably lost a lot more
lives as a result of torture then than
we saved if we saved any
and rights activists speak or advocates
we don't all have to be activists we
should all be human rights advocates
because that's the basis of it's the
moral basis of our civilization to have
a set of rules that prevent cruelty
mistreatment abuse of our dignity and
our Liberty by those who have power over
us in other respects and because it's in
our interest most of the world's most
pressing problems I've always thought
are fundamentally rooted in
dysfunctional relationships between
people and their governments think about
all the conflicts of the 20th century
world war two was fundamentally rooted
in the rise of regimes and countries
like Germany that were based on the
suppression of Liberty that were based
on the notion that one man or one
government could and should claim seek
absolute power over everybody else which
in turn led to conquest and war and a
crisis that we had to respond to at
enormous cost in lives the Cold War was
fundamentally rooted in the suppression
of Liberty in Eastern Europe by the
Soviet empire something that caused
enormous tension and insecurity and led
to a 50-year struggle by the United
States that also cost us a great deal
most of the conflicts that we've
responded to as a country whether the
awful war in the Balkans in Bosnia and
in Kosovo in the 1990s were were rooted
in human rights abuses the Iraq
conflicts of the last ten years
go back to 1988 89 when Saddam Hussein
was using poison gas against his own
people and the world did nothing about
it
he drew the conclusion I think from that
episode that he could get away with
anything and so he invaded Kuwait and we
had a Gulf War and then we had sanctions
and then we had an invasion